et photos elle effraie ton histoire est
aussi vrai que tu à te tais pas c'est un
charmant
leader mépris du quartier regarde
sandball insère des pièces des maraudes
je jouais quand on a une des pièces
inquiète
toujours non squat
tu seras tranquille lors personne ne le
calcul est vraiment jusqu'au jour où
à lui à moi je suivais la page a causé
qu'est ce que tu deviens un as toujours
prof quoi kevin qui compte sur toi sur
les courts de magasins comme sur moi
magma qui courent il a dit qu il devient
quoi il tient toujours le rater ou nikos
était le poison du quartier attend le
raku frère et que sa décote de 10 ans
n'ont plus rien ni coach je dis non plus
réussi et qui va lui prendre le terrain
un clochard faire leur test jusqu'au sur
mon terrain je crois que c'est comme ça
la vie ont parlé avec mon amie on
faisait une petite bavette quoi à force
de mettre des claques ont fini par s'en
prendre une pause est ce le fruit du
hasard
moi je suis pour l'ambiance tu te lèves
tu t'habilles on t'embarque je reste tu
t'assois et ont bon averti la montée
nique et puis s'il s'est lui cassé vous
d'ici la mi-août
qui l'avenir qui tous les sens et
maintenant et malawi ce contrat elle est
bloqué on dirait l'a vu eva mendes la
vieille là qui fume du shit la barre
génial
on se croise je ne peux pas ce qu'on
veut on change de banque mais la manne